what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am binge watching darius m
his stuff is very interesting because
it's very much from like a playboy you
know player type perspective so i'm
interested to see what this one is about
it's called the biggest secret i learned
about women
i'm a woman i want to see if i know the
secret
okay but before i start do not forget to
like
comment and subscribe
please subscribe like none of you listen
to this message i'm not even gonna lie
it's like i think 10 of the people that
watch are subscribed so you guys should
subscribe
because for real i'm trying to get to 15
000.
guys uh too many of you are making this
mistake you feel as though that
if i keep trying if i keep going and uh
you know text her a lot and do all these
different things that
she'll eventually come around i've been
there
she looks good she got a nice booty
she's attractive and you want to make
things happen so
you feel as though if i continue my
pursuit
of her she'll recognize and reward me
i've been there many times see that's
where guys get it wrong at
you think that uh let me continue to pry
at her
and she'll uh her wall will be broken
down no
if she's not on board right away
you need to just cut the cord some guys
play the long game though
and i've seen guys win through the long
game see
the biggest secret i learned about women
is that they
operate uh like quicksand the more you
try
the more you'll sink but the less you
try
the easier it'll be they'll just come
around
too many guys getting caught in the uh
in the act of uh
constantly pursuing constantly chasing
you become chasing then you
you're texting the time and you're
investing the more you text the more you
invest
the harder it's going to be well i think
a lot of times
some guys are so desperate and girls can
smell the desperation like if your head
over here
heals for a girl and you don't know her
it's gonna come off weird just like if a
girl's head over heels for you
and she doesn't know you and has barely
spent time with you i think that's where
a lot of guys go wrong
but to play this like chasing game in a
long-term relationship
if you have to do that it's not the
right relationship for you for her
the less you do the easier it'll be and
she'll be attracted to you i'll give you
an example
it was a uh ex that i was with a few
years ago
and uh everything was going great and i
wasn't red peeled at the time but
i you know i know a few things about
women and um
you know she wanted space and she you
know said she didn't want to do it no
more she just got distant
so i wanted to know why how could i fix
things
how can i make things uh back to where
they were
and the more i tried the more i reached
out the more i called and text her
uh the more she grew distant you know
it's like quicksand the more you try
you start to sink and sink and sink so i
said man after a week or so
when she wasn't really budging i said
man i'm done
you know i left it at that and
surely two to three i think two days
later
here she comes right back that's because
i stopped trying
when you stop trying with women when you
stop really caring
i'm telling you they'll come around but
the more you
pine away and try to chop and listen
let it go it should be effortless with
women
okay a lot of you guys the emails i get
and if you need a one-on-one session
shoot me an email
okay don't be bashful the bulk of the
emails and the sessions i get
it's because men um believe that i got
to keep
trying did i mix her fix it let me fix
things let me
uh get her to like me listen it's not
going to work
a woman's attraction should be
effortless if she's either she's
attracted to you
if she's you know on board with your
program she's going with the floor or
she's not
okay but some i've seen guys play the
long game
and end up winning because they show
other qualities that
impress a girl women are like quicksand
remember
the more you try the harder it's going
to be
the less you try it and and put all that
effort now
you can let her know that you're
interested but you're constantly
pursuing
yeah and pushing the envelope this is
true no
no this is true you shouldn't spend a
lot of time on a girl that's not
actually
interested i've seen guys do it and i've
seen guys win
but if you want to like save time
you don't want to waste your time with a
girl
that's really not that into you if
that's your endgame
you're devaluing yourself the more
effort you put into her okay if she's
not on board you can kick it to the curb
and i promise you
a lot of times when you get rid of these
women they'll feel as though like okay
where's this guy
at because the more you tried the more
validation you're giving her
okay stop giving when these women these
validation
when you're trying and trying to make
stuff happen because you're hurting
yourself you're sinking
and sinking and sinking and then the
more
you try you're like man i put all this
effort i worked hard i
sent all these text messages well i'll
keep it going i keep it going
and then a lot of times the guys will
get angry
because the girl didn't reciprocate
because they put in all this time and
she like kind of showed lukewarm-ish
interest
and then the guy gets mad but if you're
going in
you really shouldn't have a lot of
expectations like live your life if she
comes around she comes right
up all your energy then you get more
frustrated and more frustrated just like
quicksand
yeah sync more frustrating and now
you're mad and angry because she doesn't
want to make stuff happen you but
yeah this is this is literally what i
was about to say
like if you're doing stuff like for a
girl and helping a girl out
you should not have any expectations of
anything in return because
my dad has always told me that the key
to life is do not
like keep your expectations low think
about it you
seen the red flags you knew from the
beginning how she was she wasn't really
on board she was making things kind of
hard she was hot and cold
listen cut those women off i always tell
you
value your time life is too short to be
uh struggling and trying to make stuff
happen and
pursuing and pursuing listen you're
gonna have to start walking away
always remember women are like quicksand
the more you try
the worse it's gonna get the farther
away you're gonna push her
but the less you try the easier it'll be
she'll come
in your direction guys get this video a
lot but
again very short-term thinking
i would be interested to hear his
thoughts on marriage something tells me
he's the type of guy that doesn't
believe in marriage and or want it
but let me know in the comments if i'm
right if i'm wrong or if there's a video
that you guys want me to react to
anyways i'll talk to you guys next time
don't forget to subscribe